[Music]
hello today is wednesday december 9 and
these are the most relevant news
of the day pressure what else announced that it will
postpone its opening date which
was scheduled for january 15
of next year here in las vegas'
dripping verdigris is found  at the old site
at the hardware court out and officials
reported that despite the fact that they are on
time with the construction and
renovations of the property, the decision
to delay the premiere is due to the
pandemic for now, the company has not revealed
the new date of the great  Grand Opening
and Plans Unveiled for
Construction of a New Casino and Hotel
in Henderson Mark Knowles
Gaming Management Company unveiled plans
to develop a new hotel and casino
near Las Vegas Boulevards on Roses
Parkway near the investor
Registration documents indicate that  henderson city council will
discuss the sale
of the $250 million worth of land
this week
the religious sector is pi  Giving the
state to allow more parishioners in its
churches Nevada Supreme Court judges will
hear arguments today from two
churches who say
coronavirus safety restrictions violate their
First Amendment rights They
also debate that the same regulations
are not being applied to casinos  and other
businesses in the state currently
all examples are under strict
capacity limitations
the nevada supreme court has decided
not to overturn the
november election results in its decision
on tuesday night the
court unanimously settled with a lower court judge
who  the evidence presented does not
show that there was mass vote fraud
in the state president-elect job
airén won the state's six electoral votes
with more than 33,000 more votes
than his opponent president
donald trump
if you want to get tested for
coronavirus today tomorrow  clark county
next to the southern nevada health district
is  they will be doing tryouts in the
rye high school gym
for free this will be from
8am to noon or until
supplies run out
and we move on to see what temperatures await us
this week in the
extended forecast today with high
cloudiness  and temperatures at a
maximum of 67 degrees and a minimum of 40
degrees on Friday a little wind arrives in
the valley and this will cause us to have
a slight decrease over the weekend that is
all the information for today
I inform you of andrés gonzález and  this was
about the news now in
spanish
[Music]